this video is sponsored by one of my personal
favorite Services rocket money
more on them after the reaction
people citizens of the reject Nation we are
reject merched out today looking like Kingpin
out of the greatest Marvel series Hawkeye all
righty well we have made our way to episode 4
if you didn't catch our reactions through episode
1 through three that is up here on the channel of
course how are you guys enjoying this series
you're liking it I see mixed reviews on social
media we got to watch the first three early we
were watching this in real time with everyone
else maybe just 2 hours ahead John how are
you buttered Like Biscuits G how are you I
get it all right Coy how are you I don't get
it but I'm excited to be explained it later
I was lying to him all righty guys we'll leave a
like on this video that would mean a lot also be
sure to subscribe click that notification Bell
of course cuz we got one more episode to get
through thank you to prepper for helping us set
it down these highlights and thank you to all who
have already joined us at our patreon page I'm
assuming so I'm time traveling here that's where
you get the full length Reaction watch along
where you sync up with your own copy of echo
available for super sex Rejects and of course
we cover several things exclusively over there
with highlights and watch alongs included I'm
ready to check this out I'm excited let's do it
guys I sense New York flashback does anyone
else I hear horns of New York walking here
yep oh going back to Avengers nope
take it back going back to Iron
Man oh it's the opening trailer scene hi what
are you having huh what are you saying I don't
read pointing to things I'm going to
be really uncomfortable about it one
use your words ouch dude she's W I love
him pretty things this guy being such a
bully they're so nice in New York known for you
mean to tell me you can't read that much body
language wait here Maya uncle has something
he needs to do I need to go smash this
guy come here yes ooh crush his head
with some frozen treats I like how
he gets her in the alley so she can't
see it but he's doing it he needs it
nice there you go there you go get
some blood Splat on that white oh
yeah come on show us Marvel this guy's going
to beat up Spider-Man so good yeah am blood
blood give me it that's seled wetly
it is squelch intensifies inch your
way to feeling like the Netflix yes punch
by punch need a new jacket I don't want
my
uhoh can I do that teach me don't be afraid I love
you I don't know if this was the reaction
with should have all felt but certainly
did interesting it really feels like the
early 2000s movies like Daredevil like Ben
affle to your final lesson well we'll still
have our our Sunday evening dinners but your
tutelage has come to an end you're ready you're
a man now for what to move from the theoretical
to the Practical oh man this really feels like
Kingpin I love the way he like the clip of his
voice we are the only one once we can trust
that's your final lesson okay okay you're
dismissed this looks and feels straight out of
the Netflix show these scenes whenever in the
penthouse Suites and stuff yeah just the
way the camera moves and the soundtracks
buddy oh is she about to get taken out what
no oh oh The Interpreter yeah wow she did
too much it's messed up Maya wow now I don't
know what you're saying we could no longer
communicate I did not think this through
Maya I'm just going to have to kill a lot
of inter maybe that's why he learned before
the Hawkeye appearance cuz he's like I don't
trust interprets I'm going have to learn could
be maybe there will be an actual story behind
that like a cyclops he just wants
a hug he didn't show up alone
uh whoa what are we doing a
contact oh so they can communicate please talk
that's awesome that should be invented if it
hasn't been what yes that's neat I commissioned
a few accessories so I wouldn't have to learn I
thought it was important that we could communicate
with no go between I killed so many interpreters
de yes you made that very clear in New York
a few years ago this would have been goofy
but you know that we can actually develop some
[__] like this now oh yeah like we're probably
just a few years away the Apple lens thing will
probably have something similar I thought that
we could have a Sunday family dinner like
we used to I love this a picnic here in the
yard semantics tomato tomato potato
potato this was supposed to be Eight Episodes
originally right really I think it supposed to be
more than five yeah I would have assumed six but I
could I could feel that it was really should have
dived a little more deep into the backstory not
angry with you Maya despite oh the little souvenir
you left me with didn't look that bad but you did
what you thought you had to just like I taught you
and I was impressed this was another test I think
there's a part of you that's happy that I'm still
alive but your face it told another story just now
when you saw me I like how you hear a
little bit of the audio it hurts that
you were so ready to believe the worst
you raised a hand to me in violence the
hand I thought you saw my actions as heroic
it's good see work always had your back even
then I couldn't stand when you would get hurt
look at my scar he looks so cool that hasn't
changed who do I trust they should create some VR
experience just watching this through the Echoes
POV you have to level with her
about your dad oh damn it that's
mean I like the Simplicity of this seamwork
here the emphasis on what happened to the
Lett cookies from the Bain are they still your
favorite good no but yeah let's hope those
don't go the way of the wine this is the
best scene out of the whole series it's
just he's got so much presence to him
always yes great
timing I feel like this is when I feel the most
of her body language more of the Nuance can't
refuse I have a proposition you want an Empire
you'll have it why you can have everything all
you have to do is come home with me I love when
they choose to use the timing of it is always
interesting cuz it's a connection it's like an
intimacy I think we feel more for her cuz we
were like in her head in so many ways I'm leaving
to New York this weekend until then I'm at the
Chaka Casino no I like the complexity of that
scene a lot because I believe what he's saying
and she fears for her life well and yeah just
the conflict of like I've chosen and I made a
fresh choice to reject this but also the parts
that must be holding on still dinner all the
threats of violence with the trust it's very
interesting he's handing me Queen pin please
tell me you're not that stupid I know you can
that that's what scares me I would love it if
she becomes a villain she's going to be Shan
Chi's sister with the 10 Rings you know why
I'm 45 and alone because every I cared about
was taken away by him bucket of blood to your
left after your father died I tried to get out
who is this guy he is so good dude Fisk threaten
to kill me I came back here and did his dirty
work and I don't want you to become me he's so
good at emoting with his hands and mouth and
Body Language it's like three different acting
skills was confused this another really
good scene of character work this is like
a million years better than freaking secret
oh yeah oh 100 think this Marvel show it is
really good yeah I just I don't agree with
a lot of parts I agree with but I don't feel
like what I agree with outweighs what I
really like yeah it has flaws certainly
but they're this big compared to I think the
good pass me one of those bulbs would you sure
F oh so she's really connected to her
ancestors cuz she seems at peace with
it I am wondering if this will seamlessly
blend though Spirits are calling
out through generations come on M stay with
me cool great cut cuz the grandma before
the uh woman died at the beginning of the
first episode you know she was talking about
how ancestors are speaking to me and I feel
like it was probably a very literal thing
yeah I think it's a direct line to her but
she's more connected because of how closer she
was right cuz she'd be like three generations
away one more reunion there's something
going on Chola can help you and I think
her performance this episode is
great yeah whoever directed this
one directed the characters so much more
interestingly yeah I think she's great
here she's got so much going on behind her
like Stony facade it feels weighted the dream
catcher do you only thing I'm worried about
is I saw the run time was really small than
the last episode oh no this is really good
so far I know this episode's pretty great to
me in your head Z
are places your spirit has been
to Cosmic dust passed down to
you people playing a game that reminds
me of quiddit w i saw when I was in high
school you describing I love the wide-eyed
like fear spectacle oh I gave birth oh wow
your mother doctors at the hospital found
complications as my pregnancy we were both
in danger it's in God's hands they said
oh whoa oh that's her I found me took me
out at a white Hospital brought me to a
midwife sure where I could be surrounded
by my sisters I knew I couldn't trust
Kaiser permanent ever they rejected my
PO d That's you
damn oh nice cool it's cool the shape comes into
formations
Neo it's like its own sort of ancestral plane
I could hardly say they were always with me
they had an ability to know when they were
truly needed like when chloroform is about to
reach on of Maya's mouth yeah that night with
your mother and I it was a life death or deal
sure wow
wowe who came into this squ and
said about lifting the pain of
others this is the most epic birth
I've ever seen TR she was a Healer
mother when your mother was
killed a I
see uh not you your father
father from the father has
his perspective so much like I
think Generations are echoing no is
your name theyve been like backto
back really good characters I know
three a banger episode time would be
yeah instead she got a Kingpin nature versus
nurture I was going to say that nature nurtur
is real in this episode your whoa you could hear
her I wonder if they turn the mics up a lot of her
scenes for that so good in this epe different
but it's so different she's so she's great the
build of the character and I feel like if they
consistently ground the mysticism into like the
Heritage and the emotionality of the characters
and her being an anchor to it cuz i' I've been
consistently worried like how are they going to
blend like stre [__] with no she's about to
bust out the 10 rings and the bangle and all sorts
of other stuff but it is interesting how the night
before she gets the offer to be Queen pin and
then the morning she learns the truth about her
ancestry it's a to pre dichotomy Co it is
great song poll am I totally missing why there's
prob people like bashing on the show if I can
really see it and I'm having like the hardest time
it's people are looking really good man I think so
it's gotten better like each episode yeah I'd say
there's something here to fix Pok truck everything
the light touches is yours Ain that from Lion King
biscuits knows is Disney all right cha always says
there's nothing too broke to fix if you want
it bad enough don't throw it away a beautiful
metaphor look damage cars echoing throughout the
lot cuz we're all damaged and the traumatic you
know Heritage passed down from the death
of the American Auto industry you know
oh she's going to have the coolest super suit
and also the background and the the journeys
that her relatives have gone on affect her origin
very much so and sporting characters are so much
more interesting because of that they're
actually related oh that's so cool it is a
tapestry Maya we are playing black
jack come play craps with they all four
oh my God he is Robert DeNiro from killers
of the flower Moon yeah I was going to say
just move in here you know buy a steak take
the profits I suspect you've come to kill me
again she got a gun pointed yep the other
eye I suspect this weapon aimed at me is
to shoot me I can't remember a time when I
haven't loved you like a daughter don't you
remember oof you knew what you were part of
at every turn all the people you killed for
me did you plead for their lives she influenced
when she was a child I ask you who's the monster
but he's always thought of himself as someone
doing the right thing so he would see it that
way this is 100% a sequel to D cuz we don't
care about that other king that's what tyrants
do pointed that out so much it's glaring
where her whole family learned for her he
was negligent to even try I was there for you
I know now that I failed you I keep this with
me it's to remind myself where I come from oh
yeah what's going is it going to be a head is
it a shrunken head GTH Pal's head no it'll
be it'll be the guy from Reacher's head pass
on to you ah the hammer that killed the dad
there you go my father felt stronger when he
beat my mother do you feel like a Mayon I got
strong enough to stop him with that Netflix is
getting I was raised by you and
then you killed my dad I killed
him to be free to move forward in my
life what are you offering right now
so enough games kill me here free
yourself go ahead wow manipulative
tactic do it yourself
stop taking orders you and I Maya come full
circle he knew she wouldn't in the morning
come home just sometimes there's like that one
little is in the editing I think like the whole
scene was great up until after like the little
a little tiny beat after I'm like oh this should
just I know it sounds ni I feel the suspense being
trimmed shorter yeah but then after she puts the
hammer down like all right moving along God damn
was great only got five episodes got to move it
along yeah sometimes there's like
little editing things oh that's the
deleted scene from Hawkeye it's
Canon that laugh too uhoh the
conflict where's you laying in all these
flashbacks huh yeah where her her macaroni
is this the first we've heard her score
this is her score sounds like an echo
theme what gave you that idea I don't know
it feels like a superhero like theme building
I think it's just just cool music just
composed music for the show I'mma call
it a theme I'm sorry Mr Fisk we tailed
her but she's gone where's she gone slam
someone's head against the jet door yes
pick the front wheel of the jet up and
Crush dude his lost eye is a superpower now damn
look at that ear hole oh no there's a earpiece
okay I thought he just had really deep ears oh
sir you broke the plane we're going to have to
switch to a whole new plane dop dope sauce dope
sauce dope sauce we got some thoughts then we got
one more episode but I want to appreciate this one
in the meantime because that was best one of them
all I hope five doesn't ruin it with its really
short runtime like Disney Plus usually does but
before we start talking about that I did want
to share with you guys how Wilson Fisk managed
to get all his finances in order to maintain such
great wealth over New York City probably with the
help of today's sponsor one that I actually use
and has really helped me out with tax season so
please give it a listen and support the channel by
uh getting yourself some rocket money thank you to
Rocket money for sponsoring this video a brand
that I am happy to be partnered with thrilled
to it's fortunately one that I have been using
for quite a while now prior to ever agreeing to
a partnership with them I was like that makes for
the best kind of synergy promotion because I can
actually talk about them from my heart here reason
being like many of you guys U like for years I
constantly downloading all kinds of financial apps
that I keep forgetting to use or I don't really
find quite as beneficial rocket money has been
the one the only one I'm not just saying it is the
only one that I have been able to consistently use
rely on that has been an absolute game Cher for me
on a very personal note running real rejects is an
absolute privilege however you know like I stress
out about taxes and it's the beginning of the
year and I'm like I'm trying to be smarter and
get it all done now I already started like
a couple months ago getting things in order
managing real rejects finances while managing
my own personal finances has been an ongoing
struggle and I'm very big on like efficiency and
being organized but clearly wasn't as good enough
as I uh thought I had been so before rocket money
came into my life I was drowning in subscription
and struggling to keep track of my expenses
and as I really wanted to like get everything
in order rocket money came at the right time for
me I was overwhelmed with subscriptions I didn't
even know I had or had still been subscribed to I
mean do you ever wonder how many subscriptions you
actually pay for have you ever taking the time to
really do it it could be a little daunting rocket
money helped me see what I was missing and best
part they even cancelled those subscriptions for
me with just a simple tap so with rocket money
you can have all your subscriptions in one place
making it easy to cancel anything unnecessary
are without the hassle of dealing with customer
service my is so annoying plus they'll work on
getting you refunds and negotiate lower bills
saving you up to 20% you just snap a pick of your
bill and let Rocky money take care of the rest let
me just summarize for you really quick what they
are they're a personal finance app that findes
and cancels unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps lower your bills with over 5
million users and over $500 million in cancel
subscriptions they've already saved members
an average of $720 a year they helped save me a
little bit more than that don't waste your hard
earn money on unused subscriptions cancel them
today at Rocket money.com rejects that's rocket
money.com rejects if You' heard other people
talk about them well use ours Rocky money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code rejects
you unlock special benefits and yes using them
is also a great way to support the channel same
time it's just a great way to support your bank
account cuz I cannot stress enough just how much
this app has changed the game for me take control
of your finances with rocket money and enjoy
Financial Peace of Mind all righty all righty
well since John I got to give it to John he kept
pointing something out that I did not read into
that I was like I don't know why he's harping on
this so much about why didn't he learn it had to
happen sometime in life I think in one of that
even the reaction highlights I think I like even
cut out one one of them like we need to keep the
rhythm going he keeps harping on this thing but
a cut God damn he totally like there was such an
emphasis and it was so important to the character
here about the sign language of him not learning
how to speak sign and I thought it was just kind
of a like a detail that I agreed with but I didn't
think the show took note of it in any way yeah of
him not learning it seemed like an oversight so
John please you take away the thoughts first we
do have to film five so you know you don't be a
miraculously efficient I I I love when shows uh
I love when something can put a detail in there
that uh you know it rides on your patience but
yeah that that you think is just an oversight or
a flaw and then actually becomes an intentional
choice I think that's a good example in a universe
that's been kind of marred Lately by lack of uh
consistency and and within project foresight uh
like that's a beautiful example of that and this
episode across the board I I mean you've said it
throughout the whole thing like the scene workor
the character beats and just the Nuance that we
got to explore was really affecting and really
lovely my apprehension about this whole experience
is that yeah it it it doesn't feel like it was
cut up in a blender however it does feel like
certain things were probably expanded in the 5
to 10 whatever that Original Episode count was
supposed to be it feels like there was probably
a lot more time allowed to breathe within this
world so I feel like in hindsight four episodes
now feels like we've gotten kind of like one major
scene or sequence or beat or something with every
major part of the greater Ensemble uh you know
her her friends her family those people it feels
like everybody got like an episode to do a thing
or have an impactful moment yeah um and so yeah
I'm I'm a little worried about the totality but
I think across the board the show is demonstrated
terrific work and this uh did a really nice job
to me of representing how lovely it can be when
you integrate culture and you know new kinds of
faces and voices into popular uh popular media
like this because this is doing it to me in a way
that doesn't feel like it's been tacked on or like
it's been Studio noted or like it's pandering it
just feels like part of the DNA of the show and
I would just love to see it especially like you
know in a world where reservation dogs exists and
where this kind of borrows uh you know qualities
of that show and clearly demonstrates that it can
embody them you know like I would love to I would
happily watch more of that but I think what we've
gotten is uh is quite solid and speaks to a lot of
great talent on display across the board in front
of and behind the camera absolutely absolutely
coryon I got upload a video here um so why don't
you start talking about your thought why don't you
start talking umir lot what John said I agree that
it's an ensemble piece in front and behind the
camera especially with it being a more nuanced
show and I think maybe that's why I think we we
all mentioned a couple times during this episode
because this is the first we're filming in real
time uh we did get to to review the the first
three a little earlier but this is the first
since we've seen some other people's reactions
we were we were blessed to watch the other in a
void which is always nice cuz I don't like other
people's opinions uh to to cloud my own or just
generally I just don't generally care for other
people's opin well it's just like it I think
Marvel has become synonymous with CR critical
critical thinking implies a positive whatever
the opposite of critical thinking is either
you're blindly in love with it or blindly hating
it and that's really really dangerous because it
is regardless of it being comparatively smaller in
scale it is still a behemoth of Pop Culture it's
not doing the numbers it was but it's still like
when you look at the top 10 worldwide box office
film for 2023 three were comic movies 30% to this
day is still a foundational part of Pop Culture so
I know everyone wants to talk about the bubble
bursting because it's popular to do and I know
everybody wants to complain because it's also
very popular but it is still dangerous to have
something as prevalent in pop culture to have a
knee-jerk reaction to knee-jerk love something
without seeing it or kneejerk hate something
without seeing it defeats the purpose of art
like art is about the experience so I had a really
interesting time watching this episode because
this is the first one that was tainted by people
and I really don't understand a lot of people's
perspective on the show oh thank God I was like
where are the hell is he going with I cired back
damn he is just going and going I thought you
might need time with the upload and now you're
like oh now it makes sense Vanessa I was listening
to every word the White Rabbit I was getting I was
Kingpin monologuing I've returned but no I I think
it's interesting to watch something through the
lens of having the blind experience of something
like we used to with art versus watching something
with anyone's perspective and I immediately
found because I'd seen the first three with my
own journey and with these guys perspective all of
us enjoying it for the most part going yeah it's
got its flaws but overall greater good enjoying
it it's a good time I found myself defending it
more this time and that also felt weird because
I think this was by far its strongest episode
and instead of just being able to go like this is
what I like this is what I like there was a little
voice in the back of my head going and like [__]
that like I didn't like that I was reactionary to
the to the other world of that conversation so
I think it's really interesting when you have
a bin show like this how people will perceive it
by the time it's done since you got five hours at
once you're going through the whole journey how
people are going to be reacting to it online I'm
really curious how people are going to be reacting
in the comments to this how people are going to be
seeing the show through their own lens versus the
pop culture lens of of the great Twitter sphere
of conversation because that does affect your
viewing so I think this episode was my favorite
but I also think this is the episode that won't
be for a lot of people really that's interesting
because I feel like Disney did themselves a
disservice by not releasing all five when the
show's clearly designed to be binged cuzz cuz I
think every episode you get to helps complement
the prior episode I agree so it helps make the
episodes feel more complete because of the overall
narrative they're telling even these character
moments I was trying to pull it up I would have
like this one earlier in the season what is I need
I need to just get everyone's names in front of me
so there's Maya obviously Bonnie see this what I
mean there are some things that I feel like are
would have been more flushed out in in a longer
season and I think there are things that have
been dropped I'm waiting to reserve some of those
potential criticisms depending on how the next
episode goes so in the meantime because I'm like
oh yeah Bonnie there's so much of this emphasis
on Bonnie and I'm like now at the final episode
yeah and it's just like there's one episode where
it's the Bonnie episode and now we've moved on it
feels yeah I was like okay cool you guys things up
kind of this was the Chula episode I'm looking for
okay Chula and then who's who's the guy who runs
the the roller skating ring Oh Black Crow I think
is his name I'm trying to find the names that's
the name of the skate ring is his name also black
crow I think it's part of because it's like his
ownership like John find freaking IMDb okay let's
call Black whatever all right so I I do think that
the the actual episode itself one thing that I
loved about it so much was how this as much as we
got like great moments from Kingpin here uh with
his manipulation tactics as you know oh watch me
be because he is like a violent he's like we all
know him to be this like violent Kingpin right but
he's also a domestically violent father of sorts
where he can be soft and welcoming and nurturing
but if you he's got that temper though that if
you don't fall in line he's going to take out his
rage somewhere or on someone and I I like the way
he's Illustrated that way you saw him as a lover
portrayed that way VIA even though he doesn't
like beat Vanessa or something but he takes it out
in other ways uh he's he you see him as a lover
like that in in the Netflix shows and here you're
seeing this from the father illustration that I
even though he's called Uncle it's it's definitely
like a fatherdaughter dynamic right and then uh
with and and the way how you got like scenes with
Chula fleshing out the backstory with uh the Chaka
lore and then wasn't black crow I think it's like
Henry Black Crow or something like Henry it might
be I think it's Henry Henry yeah I think this the
just the bowling alley black crow but I could be
wrong yeah I don't know we're at odds here but we
should fight it out yes but the scenes with Henry
as well where he is talking about how like Ma you
see Maya's disdain here you see Maya's pain
as well like there's so much unresolved pain
because I'm bringing up all the other supporting
characters whereas before this episode I would
feel like I think everyone's great but I'm
really not attached to Maya and this episode
maintained and even expanded Upon Our supporting
characters and it was the first time where I felt
like it magnified Maya so much like I felt for
the first time out of four episodes and maybe
that's not the best compliment to give the show
for my subjective viewing experience but this is
what I mean by how it's gotten better each episode
I really felt like this is the Echo episode even
though everyone else is like phenomenal as always
I really felt endeared and connected to her and I
thought for using an actress that is act not I
want to say using hiring an actress casting an
actress who is deaf and who has to rely solely
on you know speaking sign language her eyes her
Expressions body language maybe it was editing
maybe it's the specific scenes or maybe it's
actually her acting this time I don't know what it
was but this particular episode I was like okay we
got three scenes here where one is with two are
with Kingpin one is with Chula one is with the
roller skating rinkman my favorite superheroes
we just call Skates so you got three distinct
scenes with Maya and each one I did not feel like
was a repetitive performance from I don't forget
her Cox from a lock with Cox I did not feel it was
repetition I I thought like oh here's variety here
and and each scene I thought brought different
death and I felt to quote KO the dichotomy of the
situation she's in of now she's unpacking you know
unresolved [__] with her family she's got this
past traumatic [__] with Kingpin and she's being
pulled in two different directions right now and I
really don't know where this so so it's credit
I don't know how 5 is going to resolve I don't
know what the plot is ultimately going to lead to
but this was a very character nuanced episode and
and the thing that I have criticize most about it
is the one I felt least connected to was Maya and
this was the one I really genuinely felt connected
to her so yeah I want to add something to what you
just said because I really I think you bring up
a really good point with how she's portrayed in
this episode I think there's an element of every
like familial but in a more direct line mother
or father figure in this episode because the the
Father Figure element of Kingpin is obvious the
maternal element with the grandfa the grandmother
is obvious but I really like that there's like the
the dad that she didn't have like he seems like
the dad of the town he kind of like runs things
and like Henry seems to be like this paternal
energy to her even though it's not her father
brother almost yeah there's like an uness but I
I think what we saw in this episode from her is
it's the first time we don't have her being stoic
as a defense mechanism she's consciously letting
her defenses down because she wants to figure
something out as opposed to pushing one away
so I think it's the first time we've narratively
allowed for Ekko to kind of get to open up those
parts of her acting repertoire like The Equalizer
got to shift a little the first three episodes The
Equalizer was kind of at like defense stoic and
I get from the character perspective why that's
necessary but I said earlier when you were talking
I think that I would have liked this episode
earlier in the season it wouldn't have worked from
the storytelling standpoint but I think what I
would would have liked is to have some scenes of
her with her defenses wavering so we could have
seen some of these elements so I could get those
the colors in the pette of aloa Cox's acting cuz
here is what I loved her the most so in addition
to my earlier rant about just the general release
model what I loved about this episode was it
gave us the most colors it gave us the most
acting style choices of actors we've already loved
and we we've seen them grow and this felt like
an exponential like wof as we enter the third act
which I really liked and the thing I am concerned
about I I just can't I can't you can't ask me
just to eliminate it from my brain it's not the
way my my brain operates I don't think either of
our brains operate this way there is an awareness
that of of the history with Disney Plus shows
the Marvel shows How It Ends How It Ends and I'm
having the hardest time believing this is really
going to stick the landing I really am because I'm
like oh there's so much left there's so much left
and they're also not known to give us season twos
like Loki and what if are what if is an anthology
show with aight different little bit of a serial
connection right like it's not it's not uh
dependent on that Loki was the exception and that
took a long time to get to you know and with this
I I I'm already seeing like okay well clearly this
was underdeveloped I did find myself at certain
points with Kingpin already feeling like you know
they keep saying how important you know Maya is
to him but I really feel like we should have seen
some like flashbacks I really feel like we should
have got some history here instead of them just
talking vager about it and it it because there's
there's a F line between you know actors provide
uh writing assuming the audience like we're
going to give the audience credit and and let
them you know fill in the blank they can extract
the subtext yeah like however I I don't think
that is actually the uh positive effect I think
I think it negatively affects some of the scenes
where they could have more impact or there could
be more tension more of a internal debate for her
if we got those young adult training scene a scene
of her killing someone for him like in the comics
there's so much like lore between the two of them
it would have been nice I I gave it crap because
it was like flashback lesser flashback modern day
before the opening but the rules of Threes I would
have even preferred one more flashback instead of
just to if it was like young adult before we get
to modern day so we could have had that moment or
even just in that scene of dialogue have a moment
where we see her do something for the criminal
underbelly that kind of like puts them together
as similar before he full circles yeah I could see
like two versions here where I think it just maybe
needed one more episode think I know we haven't
finished it but I'm already at the point where
I'm thinking one more episode probably would have
helped save this a lot so that way you get a lot
of that additional meat that you really need like
like honestly seeing Bonnie's name on IMDb just
made me go because there was so much emphasis on
this Bonnie [__] they don't give you the time it
takes to one thing i' I've learned lately is you
learn a character's name when the show's doing its
job to the utmost it's like you know if you give
us enough couple of moments to connect to them
we'll remember their name and I feel like I like
everybody here but they haven't really just given
enough to connect to the point where you remember
the names and stuff like that and with Kingpin uh
uh oh I totally had something and and now it's
it's floated way out of my mind because I open
the computer it was the opening of the episode
watch along public for I am multitasking episode
I I actually was kind of frustrated by that and
I thought that while the alleyway flashback is
striking the way that moment is handled was pretty
was pretty muddy because like there should be some
kind of a a bit of a conflict nature to the punch
of like when she comes in the alley and kicks the
dude and like Kingpin has that response of like
oh [__] you saw that but like there's there's
a lot in that moment and you guys commented on
that feeling like it was like a '90s Daredevil
movie kind of experience at that point and I
think that is because it's like it's undercut
where there should be FL like we should see the
conflict of her being indoctrinated as a child
into this life she says that thing later about
like you isolated me and you you know essentially
brainwashed me into this life you just gave me a
huge Epiphany in My overall experience of comic
book films John what's that '90s and 2000s comic
book films showed us scenes from Comics because
they knew that comic fans would connect to him
they knew audience would get just enough to move
on and that's what this was that's why it felt
like it it was like let's show them as when she
was young cuz that audience will understand new
comic Stuff shows us like regular movies where
it gives us an emotional scene based on the
character that happened to be named the comic
book characters and that's why you've got things
like Dark Knight you've got things like Logan that
are just Standalone movies because they're acting
and then there's moments of iconography but when
you've got something that feels like ' 90s or
2000 it'll just show the shot and it won't do
the followup it doesn't give you the day num Ma
and I think that's why I like the Sony movies
because sometimes there's that well sometimes I'm
like I just want to have the fun and not the you
know I want to I sometimes my steak needs to be
from outb well that's where the disappointment
of some of these little like sometimes we'll
know and it's probably it's probably things
people and it's it's not inconsistent so much
to the point where it it's like B like you can
have like stretches of the show that are like 10
minutes long that are like great and then like
they'll just do this one thing you're like what
the rush that why did you rush that face what
just happened right here reminded me of what you
said because you said there's that thing of like
it's not that the show isn't giving you stuff to
go off of but there are times where it's important
to show versus trusting like oh yeah we know what
her backstory is from this one moment we can just
fill in the blank cuz we know the broad strokes
and in certain points that undercuts you like it
I think does here we do have this should have been
the Kingpin in Maya episode like in the past yeah
and I think I think two episodes really would
have helped yeah like I think a lot especially
when so much of the hindrances on like you know
her getting in touch with her origin her Roots
her and I I honestly think the the envelopment
of the world with the chalk top people in present
day is so well done like it just feels a part
of the community naturally and I love that I
don't feel any of those like common band riverse
kind of commentary no it's a lot like Miss Marvel
where it feels like oh I just get to experience
a culture I think more so than that she's lived
in white breed culture and now she's learning
about her own herited so her her eyeline is
our eyeline in a more unique way yeah it's a city
and and I I think uh I think but I think the book
ends were great and and I think the per like the
performances I I remember watching secret invade
man we really do got to watch next episode I I
do remember watching secret Invasion and feeling
as if I can objectively tell these actors are
doing a great job but I can't feel for it because
everything else is not working for me yes and here
I I could find myself being very much forgiving of
a moment that doesn't work or something that's
not but it doesn't undercut like wow the acting
here is so good and then there's also generally
a great sense of mood there's a great sense of
atmosphere the the the dramatic feels are really
felt like they really let their actors perform and
I I'm very appreciative of an episode like I don't
think there's any action here right other than the
opening scene really um there's not really action
oh the birth was so we didn't even talk about the
birth scene I was so emotional I don't even I
almost cried Greg one day will got to learn to
cry some prune juice for my good for you I need
it I want a thing I don't want I need it I think
all this like Twitter rage is so constipated
emotionally is just another version of a boy
inside who wants to cry cover your sadness both us
know both of us know this is us ended and I have
no Outlet left stlying came around abandoned me in
my time of need and then koi immediately begins to
weep Sterling so yeah that's what's happening with
koi um we out here anyway uh yeah we we got to
watch the next episode and we'll probably have the
longest discussion there but uh thank you guys so
much for being here uh I don't know what I don't
know if five's going to come out in a little bit
or is this kind of a a jumbled schedule here done
this put us in a pickle um damn you Disney damn
you for helping us out with watching the first
three early but now not knowing how to manage my
editing tests and everything else yeah thank you
guys so much and let's send this with a patron
of the day shout out Danny pancakes you have
entered the era of 2024 where you were now get
to shout out yes and it is January 2024 so we got
to Fathom what your resolution will be and I think
your resolution this year will to get yourself on
on therapy I think I think you're going to want
to go to therapy Danny look I've gotten to know
you really well see I've talked to my therapists
extensively about you my therapists constantly
like why do you know so much about this Danny
pancakes guy I'll be like it's not your freaking
business to know why I know if I tell you you're
going to send me to jail I know exactly how this
therapy session goes down so just know I know some
things about Danny pancakes and Danny pancakes
he needs therapy cuz here's the thing his legal
last name is pancakes and you know why he changed
it to that cuz the guy can't stop coping with his
depression he he just keeps eating pancakes
B cheating wasn't enough I had to personify
myself as pancake constantly drowning in pancakes
and syrup because mess because he just avoids his
pain and then what does he do he works Out hours
in the morning to burn off those pancakes it's a
vicious cycle and he has no time to get to work
it's just eating pancakes and a bunch of carbs
and sugar at night then he gets an a terrible
nice sleep because of all that sugar and card
nightmares and then he's having to work out in
the morning so go to therapy using betterhelp.com
Rejects and get yourself 10% off in some deal
promo yeah that comes along with it I don't know
yeah a year of therapy for free don't quote me
on that feel like that's a bunch of [__] it'll
fix your life in one year for free if you use
the promo code perform brain surgery on you if
you use a promo code yeah any medical procedure
you need with our promo code for the next 365
days you can get all right Danny well take some
Fiber man because you got to poop those pancakes
out